yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie on se
retrouve aujourd'hui sur hello for alors
ma dernière vidéo sur Halo date de
environ 1978 avant Jésus-Christ et je
vous rassure mon niveau à bien
évidemment pas du tout augmenté ce qui
est tout simplement génial alors j'ai
beau être l'homme le plus nul au sniper
dans
www
oh mon Dieu alors je vais être l'homme
le plus nul au sniper dans Black Ops et
bien c'est aussi le cas dans l'eau on ne
cherche pas les bonnes habitudes
évidemment re désolé les gens la carte
mémoire était pleine donc j'ai dû la
vider comme un con en pleine vidéo et
donc si vous avez vu cette magnifique
double feed et cette explosion de
cerveau à la grue qui était magistrale
alors bon forcément des gens diront
pourquoi tu fais pas plus de sur allô
pourquoi machin bah écoutez je suis pas
plus de vidéos sur tel ou tel jeu on va
juste essayer de tuer assistance hop hop
c'est au feeling et je voulais juste
vous parler de la mort de Game la fin de
game parce que moi et game c'était un
peu le jeu vidéo le magasin de jeux
vidéo pardon dans lequel j'allais tout
le temps quand j'étais petit alors là je
vais mettre une je vais mettre pardon
une musique très très triste en fond de
la vidéo pour vous montrer mon fils de
[ __ ]
voilà ça allait très bien avec la
musique triste et oui en effet c'est la
fin de game qui a fait faillite il y a
quelques semaines déjà et je voulais
juste passer un petit mot à game pour
tous ces moments de bonheur passer à
regarder des jeux vidéo dans les rayons
et donc voilà Red Bull nous a permis de
d'être debout tout simplement de tenir
debout et franchement on a rigolé on a
on a tout simplement bah on a fait des
plats énormes on a fait des délires
énormes des blagues de beauf énorme et
voilà juste pour vous dire que il y a le
trailer qui a déjà disponible vous
pouvez passer par la description et
voilà et moi de mon côté je sortirai un
petit trailer ou quoi sur ma chaîne pour
annoncer l'épisode 2 mois il y aura
plusieurs épisodes un ou c'est celle qui
passe hein ou c'est cortex ça ou c'est
moins on s'aide enfin bref voilà je lui
aussi vous parler de l'effet c'est un
beau une vidéo où je parle un peu de
tout ce que j'ai envie de parler hein
logique je parle de son Opal ça peut
être en train de parler bref c'était
boom oh yes boum boum yes on continue
ton équipe ton équipe fatal et merde
ouais donc franchement
le le tournage était était bien et on en
passe excusez-moi je suis perturbé parce
que j'ai reçu un sms que j'étais en
train de lire ce dont vous parlant
bordel et on est en face au nuit blanche
écoutez je vais pas vous mentir j'avais
rarement fait de nuit blanche de toute
ma vie vraiment très très rarement euh
dans le sens où je sais pas je me couche
toujours à 5h pour me lever au moins à
10h enfin je me je l'ai ou ou alors je
me couche à 8h mais à 13h bref je fais
jamais une nuit sans dormir du tout ou
c'était beau ça vraiment jamais jamais
et là écoutez j'en ai fait j'ai tenu
jusqu'à 7h mais je peux vous dire vous
savez très bien que la piscine c'est
comme moi que c'est un truc qui crève
c'est un truc ça te bouffe tu es fort
mais jusqu'à la dernière c'est assez
fatale et là et là franchement une nuit
blanche en plus de la piscine c'est quoi
ça c'est quoi ça
et donc là ouais à l'hôtel et tout de
retour à l'hôtel on s'est couché on
était tous d'aide on a défoncé mais
vraiment d'aide en mode oh vous savez
quand on est fatigué à un très très haut
stade on entre dans un espèce d'état
second ou genre un état où tu rigoles à
n'importe quelle blague de beauf genre
cortex ici il avait un espèce de grain
de beauté qui ressortait mais vu que
c'est un black bah grain de beauté était
et tes couleurs Coco Pops et ça avait la
forme à Coco Pops et du coup avec
azatomy quand vous êtes alors Monsieur
coco pop on rigolez pendant 10 minutes
alors c'est une blague nul là si tu n'es
pas fatigué tu ne rigole absolument pas
mais quand tu es fatigué ouh toutes les
choses pas drôles le deviennent et c'est
juste magique enfin bref
un peu une anecdote nulle très très nul
en raison et voilà
oh là là
je vais me rattraper là
dans ton crâne c'est la grenade que j'ai
dans Halo et voilà Friday châtiment
recharge ça mais ça va là je joue pas
trop mal pour un mec qui joue jamais je
trouve enfin je dis ça je dois être
derrière l'équipe et je dois jouer
totalement comme une merde boum boum
boum boum boum boum
allez victoire oh je suis deuxième bon
allez on s'est gavé les gens c'est juste
gavé c'est juste trop gavé et voilà
c'était juste une petite vidéo bah pour
vous dire des petites bêtises comme ça
j'ai oublié qu'il y avait la caméra je
me suis mis un gros doigt dans le nez ah
super donc voilà écoutez on se retrouve
très bientôt pour un nouveau podcast et
pour la vidéo du mardi gras je pense que
vous avez grave rigolé et puis voilà on
se retrouve bientôt tchao tout le monde
peace
et on va faire test
1 2 1 2 1 2
c'est un test un peu nul allez go